cool so hi my name is Roman I work at
Netflix in the machine learning
infrastructure team and I here today
talk to you guys about how we deploy
machine models as micro-services or how
we help data scientists deploy such
models at Netflix so to start when you
think machine learning at Netflix you're
probably thinking well your title page
so the layout of the page the ROS what
it's showing each rows the title art for
each title that gets picked all that and
yes that is all machine learning and
that's all what we call personalization
and that definitely happens and we do a
lot of it this has happens for a really
long time for you guys old enough like
me to remember the Netflix prize this is
what it was about where a Netflix would
or paid a million dollars to people who
could design a better algorithm that
they than they did at the time um so
yeah that's all I Mel but that's not
everything that ml is used for at
Netflix we use it a lot in business
critical applications that are not
initially user facing but so that you
don't necessarily see when you go to the
netflix page so we use ml to inform a
lot of business decisions around you to
churn genres that people are interested
in the value of the content so how much
we should be paying for a particular
content production schedules release
dates a whole bunch of things like that
better targeting for marketing campaigns
all that uses ml it's quite important
because as you may know that flip spins
upwards of twelve billion dollars a year
on content and other production cost so
being able to do that in a more rational
manner is very very helpful for Netflix
so that's what this talk is about it's
about how we deploy these models
internally so not how we do
personalization that's a completely
separate organization so my team is
focused on machine models that are used
in these other categories so how many
that work how does one of these models
gets used or I was one of these cases so
well say you have an executive
read in this case everyone knows him he
has a question about something that ml
can inform him on so like for example he
wants to know the predicted number of
users that will watch a particular show
with him when it's released initially so
what will probably happen is he'll you
know in put this information into some
sort of UI and part of my artistic work
my daughter's for and she draws a lot
and I thought I would give it a try I'm
probably less successful than she is but
that's my attempt anyway so Reid goes to
a UI and puts the title to a movie and
you know this will go in some back-end
somewhere hosted on sir get some data
about the model get the input from read
and process the request then return the
result back importantly here this is
something that's real time it's not a
batch processing result that he's
interested in he wants to give it some
data in this case the title but it can
be something a little bit more
complicated get some other data or some
training data that has already been
produced and return a result and we want
to keep track of this we want to figure
out you know what the request was and
what the response was so that if for
example later on Reid figures out that
he was misled by this model we can
actually go back and improve the model
so this can all be done today so if
you're not familiar with these terms
it's okay it's not important for the
rest of the talk but just if you are you
can have a flask app in the front we use
s3 as data storage it's that's like so
you have your data somewhere living in
s3 you can handle your logs in Cabana
whole bunch of stuff that all this can
work today so my talk is about
describing how we do this better at
Netflix or how we do this more
efficiently
so just to recap a little bit after your
data extraction and training to use this
cases that I covered for the models are
the one the recommendations so the one
that you're all familiar with the
business use cases and just for
completeness sakes there's two other use
cases that occur
really frequently Netflix one is batch
processing which you're all familiar
with and then the other one is some sort
of a unicorn use case where data
scientists are just interested in
figuring out you know trying out a
particular models it's a single use
model kind of thing all these use cases
have extremely different usage
characteristics and that what makes them
interesting the first one very high SLA
clearly when you get to your web your
page on Netflix or your app or wherever
we want your recommendations to come out
really really quickly otherwise it's a
bad user experience bad user experience
means less revenue things happen so very
high QP is very strict SLA for the first
use case if I can use case batch
processing those are kind of background
processes we don't really care when it
happens we just want them to happen at
some point there's are a little
different cheating logic into what
happens in a batch process usually just
happen things something to run and you
just kind of run it whenever you there's
time third use case quick
experimentation we really want people to
be able to try out different models we
want people to be able to you know be
productive basically but there's no real
SLA this is kind of a one use case so
people just want to try their model get
results and move on to something else in
the last case that I had described
earlier it's very important that it
works it doesn't have the same SLA
requirements as the first one because it
goes down at 3 a.m. while the executive
who was up at that time for whatever
reason can actually wait till 8 in the
morning to get his result and and things
won't break
loke ups not that mean request but
they're important ones so we actually
want to make sure that they're treated
okay so who deploys these models is
basically the question in the first two
cases it kind of makes sense that the
engineer does it for the first case it's
kind of obvious given that there's such
a high performance requirement engineers
are the ones that are most apt at
knowing how the systems work so they
have to work in collaborations with data
scientists so that they can deploy these
services the most in the most effective
way the batch processing the engineers
can also be involved is written like I
said there's very little differentiating
logic so it doesn't
the data scientist doesn't really have
any input to bring here the next two
cases are the interesting ones just
should it be the data scientists or the
engineers that are in charge of those
use cases so let's think about it
there's three ways of going about this
pretty much the first way is to
collaborate deploy it which is kind of
let the recommendation system so you
have both the engineers and the diet
data scientists that deploy this there's
a problem with this on the Left yep your
left you'll have what the engineer kind
of talks about so the kind of low level
or lower level concepts on the right
data scientist isn't really interested
in anything on the left he's more
interested in code logic you know how
the request gets ogni how they can see
their results and things like that so
you kind of get this and actually it was
kind of funny because on Monday yes uh
yesterday Lauren gave this talk and
there was the slide in it where it's a
little sorry this is a picture I took of
the slide so it's a little hazy but it
says that the interaction between Lauren
or her team and the IT of data of the
engineer basically is when access is
needed or a project moves from modeling
to deployment only IT can get it done
and you have the you know communicate
time line needs in writing as much
notice as possible so you can see here
that interactions between you know
engineers and data scientist aren't
always great because the engineers are
overloaded the data scientist wants to
get the work done so everyone kind of
gets becomes frustrated out of this
relationship and you know everyone has
the best of intentions but this is kind
of what happens so okay so that's not
great we could potentially ask the
engineer to also deploy the service okay
so I'd say David the engineer here a
happy guy a data scientist comes around
and says oh I have my model I have my
data
sorry tethering my artwork wasn't
awesome but you know and here's the
results that I want to kind of produce
so David comes along and helps the data
scientist and that kind of works okay
and then another data scientist comes
along and David's starting to feel a
little bit more pressure here on our
team were six people and we have a
hundred plus data scientist and they're
very productive so you quickly get into
this situation at this point Dave is not
feeling so hot so it becomes really
unmanageable really quickly so it's not
great okay so that doesn't work either
way so okay now we can ask the data
scientist to do it it's like okay
engineers happy because it doesn't have
to deal with 100 plus data scientists
and their models so Kerry wants to
basically write a function that says I
want to do something in my service so
okay so Kari starts writing her function
everything's good
and then she's told by you know the
engineers well you need to deploy it to
some server that has a REST API and so
you know okay so Kerry's like okay fine
like trying to figure this out and goes
ahead and tries to figure this out and
then you know she follows along and say
okay now you need to deploy this in some
server Bank using something called
docker by this point Carrie's kind of
losing interest and then you know there
may be multiple blue guys over here kind
of querying listen so you know a load
balancer and multiple instances and then
finally Kari says well but you know I
have multiple models and they might have
multiple versions and so you get this so
Kerry's not great here either
so this is not perfect so none of these
solutions are great at Netflix we
actually want to Kari to be happy and we
want David to be happy and we want both
of them to be productive so this is what
we're trying to do and we want to get to
this solution or Kari back to being
happy writes a very simple function that
defines an endpoint and returns the
obvious answer to every question and
something else in this case what I will
be describing is
called meta flow takes care of
everything else underneath it and the
engineer doesn't have to be involved
Kari can do this all on her own
and and gets what you much so to recap
basically we want data scientists to own
deployment of their own micro services
without involving engineers and when I
talk to engineers to provide basically
this state a scientists focused path
path to deploy micro services not
talking about flask J unicorn docker
whatever something that data scientist
you know in the world as a data
scientist so this helps the engineer
increased their leverage say it's a
truckload of time and then the data
scientist doesn't have to deal with the
underlying intricacies doesn't have to
figure out what base version of the ami
is being used or anything like that that
you know make things fun for engineers
like myself so the character exists that
we're looking for in the system is we
want a simple definition
simple deployment traceable and
reproducible debuggable and version of
all the reason for this well I kind of
went over the reasoning for why simple
we wanted to actually be useful and used
traceable and reproducible I kind of
touched on that earlier we want a model
that produces a result we want to be
able to figure out what result had
produced in case the answer was
incorrect or wasn't one that was
expected and we want it to be
reproducible so you can debug it later
speaking of reproducibility one of my
colleagues Frost will be giving a talk
on reproducibility in meta flow this
afternoon at 4:30 in this room we want
it to be debuggable
again so the data scientist is kind of
self-serve and can actually work out any
problems that come up and version able
because multiple models may be deployed
and for the same model you may have
multiple training runs and you may want
to serve up the inference from all of
those at the same time you want to kind
of keep track of which is which so as I
mentioned the tool that we have at
Netflix to do this is called meta flow
and so this is what I will be describing
just to be clear you could do this in
another way you could have other tools
that do this I'm just describing it in
the car
Mehta flu so I'll give a brief primer
about what meta flu is this is not
excuse me
it's not a full explanation of meta flow
there's other talks online that you can
find if you google meta flow that will
give you a much more detailed view but
this is just to help you understand how
it works and how it's useful in hosting
so a basic computation in DES designed
to host other places is that you have
some input you do some computation and
you produce some output and you know you
can kind of view this is the very simple
Python code on that right there so meta
flow allows you to define your ml
workflow in a similar way but we do it
using a directed acyclic graph or dag so
this is actual code from meta flow on
the right that's how you would write it
you'd annotate your functions with the
step decorator that just says that this
is a step in your flow so a little bit
of terminology we call this the entire
thing the whole dag a flow a run is an
instance of this flow so it's basically
an execution with particular input set
that you run and then each node in the
graph here we call it a step and a step
can potentially have multiple tasks that
are associated with it it's not visible
here but potentially you could have what
we call a for each step which has a
dynamic element in the number of
branches that are used here you just
have the step start a B join an end so
meta flow always has to start and then
and then stuff in between so why do we
do it in tag well it has some advantages
you can see that each of these is kind
of a process and actually it is so each
node is a separate process that can run
either on the same machine or can be
distributed across multiple machines
very easily so it's kind of scalable
particularly like I said when you have
this dynamic when you have this dynamic
for each node and it also has good
properties of natural
natural checkpointing so the state can
be saved at each of these notes so it's
well contained I couldn't we do a whole
bunch of nice things with that like you
can resume your flows you can save state
you can inspect each of your steps etc
so I'm it's it's pretty nice for whole
bunch of reasons the other nice part
about it is data so if the previous
slide so each of the step is a process
you might be wondering how data moves
around between them so suppose you have
this very simple data movement where you
initialize X 0 initially and then one
node you increment it to 3 the next one
by 2 and the last one you just take the
maximum just carry that on so at the end
of the start step well
meta flow does under the hood and
internally and this is not something the
data scientist has to worry about the
data scientists just write self dot x
equals 0 what meta flow does internally
is at the end of it it will hash all the
values that are assigned to self trying
to compute a key it was is the key to
store that value in s3 as you can see in
a little cloud on the bottom or any of
your cloud provider or a key values of
provider and and then it will also
record that in this particular step so
identified by the flow number the step
name and some ID you'll have to worry
about that X corresponds to this hash
and now when a wants to add 3 to value X
needs to look up what the value of x was
first and so what it does is it does the
rehearse it takes it'll go into this map
lookup the hash for the key that X
corresponds to it and fetch that value
from s3 lazily load it into the process
that's running and do the computation on
it and then things go on so at the end
of a the same thing happens all the
values are again hashed and stored so at
the end of the process you end up with
something like this where you have the
values that are stored in the cloud and
some sort of mapping that is kept for
what a hash is present where so the
hashing allows for kind of an automatic
duplication so here you see that we only
store three values
in the car so how's this useful for
hosting well if you think about it at
the end of your training everything that
you've produced all your artifacts all
your models anything that you may want
for your inference is stored in the
cloud with a nice mapping and we have
all that information that we can
magically provide to you in your hosting
so if you remember in the previous slide
with Kari who was writing returning the
answer to the world and everything now
Kari may want to return something that's
actually related to her training flow so
like this one that we have here so she
would write exactly the same thing that
she wants to write so just a simple
function like this the only difference
here is this auto magical self dot
artifact that float on X the syntax is a
little involved because I didn't get
into it in this talk but we can actually
get artifacts from multiple flows at the
same time so that's why the syntax a
little bit more difficult than what you
would expect but the only difference
from you know return 42 is now Kari can
return some more differentiated results
that are based on what she produced in
her flow this is completely done
automatically by meta flow the you don't
have to worry about where this X comes
from
it's just fetched from s3 in the right
way and your users so carries users then
just simply go to this URL or some
version of it like this and they will
get the result that Kari wants so in
this case there's no input produced but
you can you can see here that there's a
request dictionary which would contain
any of the request information that is
passed to Kerry's function okay so a
couple of other points about what we do
with hosting to address the issues that
we had earlier versioning so if Kerry
has two versions of her code was the
first one here she would deploy saying
I've from run zero so this run zeroes to
the first run that she did you the URL
would have like a little V zero and you
just access this way and you'd produce
three and she runs it again and then
deploys that runs you'd have v1 pretty
straightforward so you'd have two your
two different URLs and they would
produce the right result so in this case
to emphasize the code is the exact same
one there's no difference from the you
know return self dot artifact flow X it
fetches the right one it does the right
thing under the hood for you and returns
the right result we introduce another
notion so now Kerry wants the UI that we
had talked about initially to always
return you know the latest and greatest
model so she can have these two models
you can compare them she can do whatever
she wants and then at some point said
okay I want this one to be the official
ones so we have something called
promotion which basically just has the
basic URL without version number and
then picks one of the ones the one that
the data scientist wants speaking of
promotion one common use case is that
these models run multiple times and
every time they run Kerry might decide
well I want to make sure that this
deploys a new version and so we have
this that you can integrate it directly
in your training flow so you run your
training flow or you have a con job that
runs your training flow and at the end
of it you say well I now I want to
deploy it so we just have this concert
called hosting deployment that allows
you to say what you want to deploy to do
some basic testing to make sure that
your model is producing the correct
results that the audit statements and at
the end you can say okay now it's passed
everything I will promote this this
basically is nice because it's
completely side-effect free if it
doesn't pass the test then it will never
get promoted in your users don't see
that you had a work model that you know
that trained badly or something so
they'll still use the old version but if
it passes they'll get to use this
version and again you don't have to do
anything about it
okay so how did we do with our initial
requirements so a simple definition well
I think I'm hoping that all you can
agree that it's fairly straightforward
you just have to define your Python
function endpoint and everything else is
taken care of for you
simple deployment well we have a CLI
so some may argue that that's not
perfect I like command-line but you know
not the optimal we don't have a UI yet
you actually have to write your Python
your function deployed et cetera so you
know maybe a UI will come some point
traceable reproducible all API calls are
logged so it's easily redeploy able as
well since we have everything in s3 we
can easily take that whatever you had
and redeploy it so it's easy to trace
and easy to reproduce debuggable we do
have the logs but they're a little hard
to it find its quick it's a little bit
hard to kind of iterate quickly and
debug on those that's something we can
improve in we're working on version of
also we do have different versions that
are easy to parse out and there's this
notion of promotion that allows you to
kind of isolate your users from all your
versions and just get them the latest
version 81 so overall not so bad okay in
the last part of my talk I want to kind
of focus a little bit about
implementation so for the data
scientists in the rooms may be slightly
less interesting for the data for the
software engineers maybe this will give
you some ideas of how you could
potentially do something similar in your
um so um we evaluated different
solutions and I didn't put everything
that we valued with some of the ones
that we did in some of the criteria that
we wanted so we wanted basically the
service to be to produce consistent
results to be low maintenance
like I said we're six people you support
100 plus data scientist so we don't
really have time to reinvent the wheel
on everything we wanted logging tracing
for the reasons that I explained earlier
and we wanted some form of load
balancing like I said not necessarily
very high QPS but some services do have
some heavy load they do a lot of
computation so we can't just have one
box serving all of them so we explored
three solutions DNS redirect was the
pretty straightforward thing where you
just basically tell the DNS system all
your backends for a particular service
proxy which is exactly what it is and
open fast which is a
functions as a surface framework that's
open-source you could use other things
like AWS lambdas in here as well but
open fast was a project that is
developed already pretty mature and
someone was implementing it within the
Netflix infrastructure shall we use it
so the DNS solution it has really low
maintenance there's basically nothing to
do your DNS system does everything it's
not really consistent in the sense that
it is dependent on the caching
infrastructure so your DNS when you have
a client that queries the DNS it will
cache the results and that cache can
lead to some inconsistencies and if
you're updating your service or you're
deploying a new one you may not get the
you may not actually hit that new one
right away
it doesn't really have any logging or
tracing by itself DNS systems aren't
designed for that and it does some load
balancing in the sense that you can
define multiple backends for one URL so
it'll do that a little bit but it's not
ideal it's kind of more random and it's
dependent on the client implementation
and you're not really in control of it
proxy had lots of good things for pretty
much everything except that it wasn't
low maintenance we would need to
actively maintain the proxy updated et
cetera and no one was helping us for
that so we picked open fast because like
I said someone was actually implementing
it for other use cases it's consistent
since there's a single gateway it has
logging and tracing again because of the
single gateway and it has great load
balancing or at least you can implement
different load balancing strategies so
there's two things that we actually
deploy the first one is the control
plane which registers the hosted service
deploys the service it tracks promotions
and it also has the ability to log the
query since everything is going through
it it does the redirects as well the
reason for that last one in particular
is because of this notion of promotion
we have to actually look up in a
stateful manner what is the latest
version that you want to actually hit
and then we have what the user code will
run in
so the hosted service and that does all
the magic basically it downloads the
user code that is needed it downloads
all the needed artifacts that's that
self dot artifact that hello it does any
user directed initialization we have
some some use cases that need to
initialize tensorflow for example and
then it starts up HTTP server to serve
out the interrupt functions that the
users are provided and then it also
collects the longs for debug ability so
how does it work in practice or in real
life so weren't fully aware Netflix is
AWS sharp so our cloud runs in AWS we
have things like spinnaker which help us
main manage it it's an open source
project that helps you manage your
instances and there's something called
Titus which is like a kubernetes which
is our container management system so we
have this gateway open fast gateway
which is what I mentioned we were using
for the service so the first thing it
does is it will deploy the control plane
using our infrastructure so this
basically deploys an AWS instance that
runs our control plane code this is a
small code so we don't really have too
many instances these it's really
lightweight and that one has a backing
database store like I said the
promotions and any of the you know the
activity or logging information that we
want so now it comes along meta flow I
wants to deploy a service so it'll call
into the gateway saying hey I want to
deploy on a service this will forward it
to the control plane which handles these
types of requests which will register
everything into the database do any
housekeeping there and then call back
into the open fast gateway saying create
me another function which is the actual
one that I want to deploy so that will
go back to the clouds AWS and actually
create this hosted micro service
assumption and so you can have a bunch
of these of course that are deployed
either this multiple instance through
the same version or just different micro
services and now
when Reid comes along and wants to
actually do a query he will also go and
query into the open tasks gateway which
will look which will ask the control
plane hey what is Reid looking for so
this is where we do all the resolution
for the promotions which version we're
looking at so this goes into our
persistent data stored to figure out
what we want returns back to the Gateway
saying okay now I know which one you
should be forwarding to and the Gateway
actually Ford's to the proper micro
service so that's the entire system that
we have kind of a high level but as you
can see we rely heavily on existing
services so the part that we did
ourselves in our team is basically the
control plane which is a fairly
lightweight go process or go server and
then this hosted micro service which
just does the Python magic around so
again fairly lightweight for us and
everything else is kind of handled by
someone else in our team or in Netflix
ok
to conclude just a shameless plugs
multiple of them we're hiring so if
you're interested
that's the job link that you can go to
you can also send me an email that's my
email you can just see us there's a
couple of other people from my team
around here as well so just look for or
I don't know I think I'm the only one
wearing the t-shirt today but anyway
just ask me there's a talk this
afternoon like I said at 4:30 in this
room reproducibility and meta flow by
for us who will give you a bit more
detail on meta flow and how it provides
reproducibility for ML training and then
lastly we are actually going to open
source all of this the hosting part that
I described may not be available right
away but if you're interested come talk
to me otherwise yeah look for it by the
end of the year or just come talk to us
if you want to use it before and that's
it thank you so much and I'll ready for
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
hi um thank you so much that was an
awesome talk I just had a quick question
you you mentioned that the open bass was
very similar to Netflix and it sounded
like the dag architecture was very
similar to like a net or it's very
similar to a WS lambda and that has like
the step functions now so what was
Netflix is thinking for sure on using
lambda for that implementation yes so um
sorry so I talked about the lambda as
open pass right
and so that was for the hosting
deployment for the training parts of the
dag part you can run it on a on on steps
its definition early on batch actually
for open source release that will used
batch as one of the implementations as
one of the backends the lambdas are more
for the hosting size that I was kind of
saying and so we'd it was for the
basically function as a service kind of
but the you're right the the dag is a
very good fit for for example so how
abstracted is the user in meta flow from
managing environments and dependencies
and things like that
it looks like you've completely abstract
at them from like like container izing
things and stuff like that how does that
all get pieces together
yeah the user I mean our goal is to make
the data scientists life easy and not
have them worry about any of the stuff
that you know they're not paid to do in
some in some fashion so the user
basically the interface for the user is
they write pure Python code and just
basically what each of the nodes does if
you're talking about meta flow for the
training partner who said funding for
that so they just write basically each
step function and what it does and it's
just pure Python code they can use
whatever they want tensorflow whatever
we don't put any restrictions on that a
lot of users do for example pip install
at the beginning of their step to
actually get all their dependencies we
have other ways of dealing with
dependencies and for us does get into
that in the
afternoon talk as well but otherwise
that's pretty much the level of
abstraction divas that they store all
their artifacts in the self arrabal like
I mentioned and they just that is just
available to any other step going
forward I have a question about the
graph and not the graph but the chart in
the end about the process what was the
need for the repetitive process of the
CEO going to the open path and then
instead of going straight to the micro
service he wanted what was the why would
you have to go for us to the go server
and then back okay yeah that's a good
question um the reason is particularly
to do with the this notion of promotion
so open fast is completely stateless and
we need to map you're asking for my web
service which of the versions that I
have running around are the ones that I
is the one that you want to get to so
that's is looked up basically in this
database that's stored so you have to go
there query that and then go fetch and
go fetch around you're right that in the
case where you do know the version
number that you want to get you
technically don't need that loop but
it's really fast so it it's like we just
a simple thing and it also allows us to
do URL rewriting to make it look nicer
than what the open trust URL allows us
for okay thank you so much